в 14-му році я був ще в 79-й бригаді
дшб потім займався громадською
діяльністю потім зараз депутат і понині
депутат запорізької обласної ради Але да
з першого дня війни став долав
Запорізького
батальйону і Виконую завдання ну 24
лютого я був депутатом запорізької
обласної ради Ну в принципі ним зараз і
залишаюсь е з 1 березня того року з
початку війни Я вже був зарахований в
батальйон Ну бо інакшого вибора Я не мав
ми маємо захищати нашу Україну якщо не
ми це будемо робити то хто я маю
дитину Я маю свій дім і якщо я їх не
буду захищати То хто це буде робити
сьогодні Ми зустрічаємо Петра
Олексійовича Порошенка він вже котрий
раз за другий рік війни нас провідує за
завжди не з пустими руками Сьогодні він
нам передає дуже необхідний нам пікап
Джак ну і звісно смачні тортики але Джак
важливіший буде на ньому встановлени
турель з кулеметом і буде виконувати
завдання по силах і засобах оборони
Києва це вже наша не перша і не друга і
навіть не 10та зустріч Петро Олексійович
завжди допомагав нашому підрозділу це
були і вантажівки і генератори це були
дрони буржуйки
планшети легкові автомобілі ну тобто
майже все те чого не вистачає що ми самі
не в змозі там купити І що не надає
держава на жаль на сьогоднішній
[музика]
день я підціну да да батальйон
пройшов довгий складний шлях з першого
дня війни це був батальйон який
сформований в лавах ЗСУ виключно з
добровольців запорі і запорізської
області з 1 квітня 22го року ми почали
виконувати завдання на Донеччині з
травня і по січень
23го наш батальйон тримав оборону
Авдіївки на найважчому фланзі на нулях
на сході і з лютого 23го фактично по
жовтень цього року батальйон
боронив місто микіївка Луганської
області це
лимансько-куп'янське ну вітинок
лимансько-куп'янський цю задачу також
батальйон виконав Відмінно для мене не
було
складно змінити там звичайний одяг на
однострій бо ну це теж робота Люди за
нас голосували люди нам довірили бути
першими у багатьох питаннях я не вважаю
що депутат це якась окрема Каста і якщо
ти чоловік ти повинен стати на захист
своєї батьківщини в принципі в
політичній силі європейська Солідарність
дуже багато людей пішло що стосується
саме Запоріжжя Запорізької області у нас
з смох чоловіків депутатів запорізької
обласної ради служити пішло четверо
тобто більшість і вс всі вони
знаходяться в гарячих точках ніхто не
сидить в тилу настрій бадьорий ми всі
розуміємо за що йде війна ми всі
розуміємо що буде якщо скласти зброю ми
втратимо все ви втратите все країна
втратить свободу наші діти будуть
рабами і ми Також ми втратимо все що
маємо на сьогоднішній день настрій
боротись до кінця тому все що ми можемо
треба робити для посилення збройних
сил порівнюючи вашу депутатську
діяльність І от діяльність зараз що таке
От вам заразпадає в очі що кардинально
відрізняється діяльність така цивільна
заради держави і військова зараз таке
важке питання відрізняється ну це
стовідсотково ти відірваний від сім'ї
від звичайного своєго побуту
ти завжди з батальйоном тим паче що
посада головного сержанта батальйона
зобов'язує бути завжди
знаходитися в
Епіцентрі подій які виконує батальйон
завдань Тому це суттєва
різниця можете передать як це змінити от
депутатський мандат депутатське крісло
на от однострій на військову таку тяжку
роботу А відповідь проста знаєте Ну є
можливо різні депутати і десь там в
уявлені певних людей депутат - це така
людина яка має певні там блага там
насолоджується якимось таким розкісним
життям Але це не не так і це не
стосується всіх депутатів ну для мене не
було
складно змінити там звичайний одяг на
однострій бо ну це теж робота Люди за
нас голосували люди нам довірили бути
першими у багатьох питаннях люди
довірили їх представляти я собі не дуже
розумію як депутат коли почалась війна
не покаже власним прикладом або
військову свою роботу Ну як військовий
або як волонтер Ну я не вважаю що така
людина має залишатись депутатом у вас
був якийсь військовий досвід до 24
лютого Ні у мене взагалі не було
військового досвіду більше того
я обмежено придатний в принципі це мені
взагалі не за завадило виконувати свої
завдання О вже майже там другий рік з
першого дня війни І я хочу сказати
що дуже багато людей там з певними
діагнозами там відстрочками Ну насправді
можуть бути корисними на фронті не
завжди здоров'я якщо там обмежено
придатне ну не всі там копають окопи
потрібні там водії кухарі е діловоди
толкові ну тобто вибір величезний було
бажання а роботу собі в Збройних Силах
може знайти будь-хто цього не треба
боятись треба працювати